So, we have really come full circle with
AI writing. Now, I can remember not long
ago when writers went gung-ho with AI.
It seemed like a productivity miracle,
and the biggest problem in this space
was how to optimize your prompts. But
then, AI started leaving its
fingerprints all over the place. Certain
patterns kept showing up, in particular
the M dash, and readers got fed up. So,
they started fighting back. Anytime they
spotted the M dash, they called it out.
And honestly, this was a helpful
correction. But, the backlash went too
far, and now writers are terrified of
using the M dash, which is a perfectly
legitimate writing tool, for fear of
being accused of using AI. Now, I am no
fan of AI writing, but I need to be
clear here. Writers should not cede
ground to these AI witch hunts. The M
dash is ours. It's honestly one of the
most powerful tools in the writer's
toolkit, if you know how to use it
properly. So, in this video, I'm going
to show you the hidden risk of avoiding
the M dash, how expert writers have
actually been using it and misusing it,
with both good and bad examples, and the
best way to use the M dash so that you
can write clearly and effectively
without sounding like a robot. And if
you're new here, my name is William. I'm
an English professor, and I help
non-fiction writers write well. So, if
you want to learn the art and science of
expert writing, be sure to grab my free
newsletter Writer Science. Link is down
below the like button. So, there are
basically two risks that writers face
whenever they avoid the M dash for fear
of being called out for writing with AI.
And to understand these risks, just
imagine that you're driving a car, and
you think that one of your headlights
might be out. Now, you've got a visible
risk. If the police pull you over, then
they're going to give you a ticket. So,
what do you do? You turn off your
headlights, but now you're driving in
the dark, which is infinitely more
dangerous. You've avoided the visible
risk of a hypothetical traffic ticket,
but you've created an invisible risk,
which is the real chance of crashing
your car. And these are the two kinds of
risks that I see in non-fiction writing.
Just like drivers who are worried about
getting a ticket from the police,
writers are worried about the grammar
police noticing patterns in their
writing that resemble AI. But, by
avoiding these patterns, you create a
new set of problems that makes your
writing more difficult to follow and
less clear for your readers. I mean,
just look at the difference that a
well-placed em dash makes in these
sentences. Now, this example doesn't
work so well if I read it out loud to
you because the emphasis that I
naturally make with my voice is going to
do the work that the em dash is supposed
to So, just take 5 seconds and read this
quietly to yourself.
That seems a little clogged to me. What
if we replace those commas with an em
dash? It becomes, "It is remarkable that
the greatest scientific breakthroughs,
that of penicillin in 1928 and that of
DNA structure in 1953, occurred through
accidental observation." Second example,
just take 5 seconds to read it.
When Sarah opened the envelope from the
university last Tuesday, a moment she'd
been dreading for weeks, she was
surprised by the relief she felt in her
kitchen. Last example, 5 seconds and
then I'll read it aloud.
Surprisingly, creative momentum in
writing, like physical fitness in an
athlete, requires constant maintenance.
So, as I think these examples show, a
well-placed m dash goes a long way to
making your writing more clear. And if
you were paying attention to the change
in my intonation, I think the m dash has
the same effect. It gives a kind of
emphasis to that interrupting clause
that I don't really think you get with
the commas. But without the m dash, you
can end up even with comma splices or
clunky sentence breaks. Again, here's a
5-second example, and then I'll read it
aloud.
Don't worry about polishing your draft.
We'll handle that. Just make sure the
argument is sound. Now, if you're
writing online, then you probably don't
care about mistakes like comma splices
or run-on sentences. But even putting
the grammar mistakes aside, I think we
can both agree that using the commas
here just gives that interrupting clause
less emphasis. But not only does it give
it less emphasis, it also creates some
syntactic ambiguity, which is to say the
punctuation doesn't give the reader any
clues about the underlying structure
beneath the sentence. So, we writers
cannot give up the m dash. It has an
important function. But even writers who
use the m dash often mistake that
function. And as a result, they blot up
their page with dashes everywhere. Two
writers who are quite guilty of this are
Paul Graham and Marc Andreessen. I was
just reviewing their essays for this
video, looking at examples of m dash
usage, and I've got to say theirs are
all over the place. They're rather
indiscriminate in their usage of the m
dash, and they're not the only ones.
Many writers are using the m dash, what
I would say inappropriately. And I'm
really not here to wag my finger and lay
down rules, but I am here to show you
the unique effect that a well-placed em
dash can have on your prose. So, let's
get clear on what the em dash means and
how you can use it properly in your
non-fiction writing. And so, instead of
just sitting here and laying down the
rules about how I think the em dash must
be used, instead, I'm going to show you
some patterns that I've noticed in
expert writing and then I'll tell you
what joins them all together. So, here's
the first pattern that I noticed with
the usage of the em dash and it comes
from Maria Popova over at Brain Pickings
or her blog is now called Marginalia, I
think. And this passage is about the
ship of Theseus. So, it says, "As time
began to corrode the vessel, its
components were replaced one by one. New
planks, new oars, new sails until no
original part remained." This is
exemplification.
Whenever you want to give examples of
something, but you don't want to start a
whole new clause or sentence for it,
then a pair of em dashes lets you inject
these examples right into the flow of
your writing. Here's the second pattern
from Simon Sinek. "Instead of an
adolescence full of rites of passage,
where one attempts to master something
and accept responsibility, we have made
it full of waiting and doing work. For
school is work that nearly everyone
knows is fake." This is not
exemplification, but rather an aside
comment. The writer digresses slightly
from the main point, usually by
injecting their own opinion or following
a separate train of thought. And here's
a third pattern from Ryan Holiday.
"These are not things that governments
give to their people. These are things
that God or generations of evolution and
progress endowed us with at birth and
that we in turn give to governments the
power to protect." The function of this
pair of m dashes is mitigation. When the
writer makes some hedge to address
naysayers and counterarguments without
detracting from the main point. So,
those are the three different use cases
for the m dash across all the essays
that I examined. But, in every case,
what we see is that at the level of
grammar, the m dash has one function,
which is to mark the end and the
resumption of a statement. So, whatever
occurs in the middle doesn't need to
follow the same syntax. It's not bound
within the same grammar of that matrix
clause. It's more like injecting a new
thought into the middle of a sentence.
And that's a great way to make your
writing more free associative because we
don't think in complete sentences. And
often in conversation, we will allow
ourselves to get pulled in different
directions as thoughts occur to us. And
the m dash lets you capture that natural
rhythm. So, that's what the m dash does.
Those are the rules that govern it. What
we in the writing business call syntax.
But, syntax is just the mechanics.
Semantics is what it means. And when you
understand the semantics of the m dash,
which is the meaning behind the
punctuation, then you can use it more
skillfully to control your message and
make your writing much stronger. Now, as
I mentioned, writers who do use the m
dash aren't always so principled in
their usage. And in my opinion, I think
this makes it lose its rhetorical force.
It's a little bit like the word however.
And this is something I notice in my
undergraduate essays. So, sometimes
students aren't paying attention and
they just use these transitional devices
like however or furthermore all over the
place. And look, I'm not going to say
that there's something wrong with that
at the level of grammar. It's not like
it's incorrect to say however three
times in one paragraph. But when you
turn from the syntax to the semantics,
this unprincipled usage can diminish the
force of that word. Like when you're
more careful in your usage, when you
reserve however only for major turns in
the argument, I think it carries much
more strength. And the same thing goes
for the em dash. There are too many
examples of careless em dash usage to
mention, and I really don't want to call
anyone out, but one that I see time and
again is using this pair of em dashes to
give a definition of something. So for
example, here's Marc Andreessen. We
believe in accelerationism,
the conscious and deliberate propulsion
of technological development to ensure
the fulfillment of the law of
accelerating returns to ensure the
techno capital upward spiral continues
forever. And here's the same pattern
from Gwern, whose blog I love by the
way. If you want a great read, go check
out Gwern. I'll leave a link down below
the like button. We are still alienated
from one another. The rise of connected
machines still facilitates withdrawal
and isolation. It presents the specter
of the hikikomori, the person who ceases
to exist in the physical realm as much
as possible. It is a Japanese term of
course. Now again, there's nothing wrong
here from the perspective of syntax.
It's grammatically correct. But from the
perspective of semantics, I think this
is a pretty weak use case. I mean, we
already have a structure for providing
definitions, and that is the
non-restrictive relative clause, which
just means
a comma plus the word which. So for
example, Gwern could have written the
hikikomori, which refers to a person who
ceases to exist in the physical realm as
much as possible. In my opinion, that is
the structure that you want for
expressing definitions because it puts
the definition, which is not really the
main focus of the clause, into a more
subordinate position. And by contrast,
the pair of m dashes should be reserved
for emphasizing the clauses that you
think are most important without using
bold or italics and not just defining
terms. And if you want something even
quieter than a comma, that's what
parentheses are for. Parentheses present
clauses more gently and unobtrusively
than commas or m dashes. So, the m dash
is for emphasis. Use it carefully and
strategically, and it'll make your
writing hit a lot harder. But to be
honest, the m dash is only a symptom of
AI writing. The real disease is that AI
voice that sounds at once both so
confident and so hollow. And that's the
real problem that readers have with AI
outputs. So, watch this video next
because it's my ultimate guide to
writing without AI, and it's going to
show you not only how to clean up your
prose, but also how to use writing to
generate value for your readers. So, be
sure to go check it out.